Vì kia phương lượng trọng, giữ thiệu người dưỡng cửa phát huy quen làm chủ của Nhưun, trong xuất qua chính bầu cử.
Nó cấp của Idaang, cần tập trung linh nào, chỉ đạo trạch phía tổ chức, các hội hiếp thương, các cấp để lập trình xác.
Nói giả lượng cử đã biểu phu hỏi vào đúng như dân theo đúng lật định.
Phó tuy vai trọng quan trọng của mặt trận tổ khu vụ nâng và các tổ chức thành vên trong quá chính hiếp thương, giữ thiệu người dưỡng cử.
Nói giả lượng của Nhưun, giữ giảm sát, quá chính bầu cử.
Phó tuy vui trình hiếp thương và đừng tế này dân trụ, hết quan công khai mình bài theo đúng của đi phó bọn.
Tăng cường, kìm chá giảm sát, gặp thực hiện kiến quyết phong đệ sẽ ra những nghiệp tự kỳ cơ tín vận đảo không lại mài.
Chảy xuất những cử chảy phíu bảo hoặc lệ ý nhóm làm sai lại ý nghiệp bầu cử.
Mày tạo được kiện thoại nhất để mọi công dân thực hiện đây đồ quen ứng cử, quen bầu cử, của mình theo đúng là tựa đối không đẹp,
hình quy càng trở thành phép nào xâm phản quên làm su của Nhưun.